what was that are you kidding me I
thought people wanted to see my new
movie I thought they wanted to see a
comeback but instead my new movie came
in what 92 - opening weekend and 16 -
the last weekend people don't even give
a [ __ ] anymore
but Johnny said he would review my movie
because that's what kind of guy he is
he's still going to do it so let's get
this going
The Last Stand might very well be like
the shirt Purple's a man's color this is
a manly review for a man's movie from
men right so The Last Stand is like the
Arnold Schwarzenegger comeback movie but
not really because I thought The
Expendables 2 was the Arnold comeback
movie I'm back see he even said that in
the Expendables 2 so that was his
comeback movie you could argue that The
Last Stand just like his comeback solo
movie but we've already seen him come
back to the screen a very lucrative and
rare opportunity for me because I can
touch on the stats and the fact that no
one gives a [ __ ] about Arnold
Schwarzenegger movies anymore I know
this because this movie really did
terribly I've never really felt like
this for a video or a review because
usually I get the review out before
feedback comes out you know before the
weekend is over
usually anyway I never feel like you're
like I I need to do this video and waste
my time talking about something no one
cares about hopefully the sound of my
voice is enough
in any case however you want to spin it
the last dance stars Arnold
Schwarzenegger and he's the sheriff in
this really small podunk town and
trouble is about to come through because
this coke lord guy is gonna try to make
a jump for the border or a run for the
border to jump the border that sounds
grammatically correct
Arnold's gonna stop him nothing my town
I'm the sheriff so in this movie you're
like all right Arnold Schwarzenegger is
gonna be a badass and the end of the
movie he is a badass leading up to it's
gonna slow though Forest Whitaker's an
FBI agent and he's looking for this guy
so you're like all right Arnold shoot
[ __ ] I mean if this is the Arnold
comeback movie you want Arnold to just
lay waste to a lot of bad guys he has
his moments in this movie but if this is
a throwback to old Arnold movies I don't
remember old Arnold movies taking this
long to pick up pace the acting is not
good in the movie obviously Arnold's
rusty is [ __ ] you would think he's not
rusty that he's a great actor because he
spent the last few years of his life
being a politician and politicians are
good actors because they just sling
[ __ ] 24/7 but he did get caught
banging the maid so you know he's not
that good a liar though she is not that
good of an actor I'm Sharon no you're
rusty you're a rusty old guy Johnny
Knoxville's good in the movie Louis
Guzman's good in the movie there's this
one hot chick in the movie I don't even
know why she's in the movie she's just
there because they need a hot chick in
the movie it really does come across
like that and it is like that because
that's a fact hot chick bad actress I'll
say this I did take away that the bad
guy is a real
driver and his driving skills were
awesome and I liked seeing it because
you know sports cars and I'm a dude and
that [ __ ] is cool to me that being said
when the climax of the movie takes place
as a race in a cornfield where you
really can't see [ __ ] anyway you're like
this is what we get the end race scene
in the cornfield is it metaphor for the
entire movie cool things hidden by a
bunch of [ __ ]
cool shootouts do happen that's cool
Arnold is in a movie that's cool bad
guys get wasted in this movie and that's
really cool but it's hidden by a blanket
of bad acting and messy plot and slow
parts which makes you go oh okay there's
a reason this movie came in ninth this
opening weekend fact is the Expendables
2 is the Arnold comeback movie even if
it's not his solo movie I'm back because
he said that in that movie he does say
I'd be right back in this movie in one
scene but it's I'll be right back not
I'll be back I'll be right back
something you shouldn't say in a horror
movie they'll say it's Jamie Kennedy but
there is this romance going on between
this one dude and this one chick and
you're like do I give a [ __ ] about this
when the guy's not on-screen you forget
he's even part of the crew then he's on
screen again you're like oh yeah that
dude that's right forgettable characters
among bad acting no not in an Arnold
movie that just comeback movie but not
really his comeback movie because that
was Expendables 2 I'm back yeah so I
will say The Last Stand would be a good
time if you're drunk yeah I know the
body I just remember having fun with
Arnold movies more back before he was
governor now it was just kind of it's
desperate you see it you're like you're
desperate aren't you
how are you sure old you get sad you get
really sad all right so your favorite
Arnold movie of all time whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
you